to start off with a bit of a silly fun
question before jumping into some more
serious stuff i was recently reminded by
one of my co-workers of the march
madness commercials that you did with
spike lee and charles barkley
it seemed like you guys had quite a bit
of fun making so what were those like to
shoot is that how things normally tend
to go when you guys are together
well we've been doing them for a while
now um and they're fun they happen every
year we just uh we did another
uh
five or six of them you know not long
ago that will start airing pretty soon
when march madness starts so yeah it's
always great to to be able to do them
and charles charles is is so comfortable
being the butt of the joke uh that it
works out very well and we're able to
incorporate new people uh we got you
know got magic johnson now sometimes and
we got larry bird sometimes and so
it's it's a fun job to do
you've certainly
i i know you've you've previously said
that you've been
thinking of this series in your head for
you know 10 years that you've been
talking to walter mosley about doing
this for a long time
you've certainly spent a lot of time you
know getting this together did it take
10 years because
you weren't ready to do it before now or
did it just take that long to get made
um
it it took that long to get made uh it's
it's been in different places uh it's
had different writers uh they've been
trying to trying to force
an hour and a half to two hour format
down our throats for a while and i've
resisted that
at all you know um
places because i felt the story needed
to be you know
longer and aired out if you can do uh
boardwalk empire or the sopranos or
whatever you can do this in eight eight
episodes it's not a big deal but nobody
wanted to do that so that was some
resistance there and then we'd let the
rights run out and then we'd pick them
back up and run somewhere else and see
if we could do it again but we finally
reached a point where the the format and
the timing uh come together and the
characters have an opportunity to to
breathe and give an audience an
opportunity to take a trip with uh those
particular characters that hopefully is
satisfying uh and adds color and depth
to a story that i don't think could have
been told in an hour and a half do you
ever worry that if you didn't agree to
do it as a film that you might never get
to make it at all and is that something
you would have been okay with if this
never had been able to be done this way
um i guess it would have had to be i
mean there are all kinds of things that
i wish i could have done that didn't get
done or things that you know i was i was
a part of and i saw that did get done
and you said well i'm glad i didn't do
that so there's uh yeah so
either way just happens
how do you approach character do you
have a process that you always go
through when finding a character do you
work with the scripts and whatever
written research you can find do you do
a full backstory is it about the
wardrobe and the mannerisms and the
physical props for you
i mean do you have like one way that you
always approach that no there's not one
way um
you you read a story
and you connect to the story in a
specific kind of way uh then uh you hope
that uh the character that you're
attracted to or the character they want
you to play is someone that you
feel uh is integrally telling the story
that moves the story along in a specific
kind of way or that uh
gives the story a richness that it
wouldn't have without that particular
character in it and you find a way to
inhabit that character uh ptolemy i've
been talking to
uh my makeup artist for a very long time
about it i talked to jake about this
thing i don't know five six years i've
been telling them i'm trying to play
somebody that's 100 years old and i'm
gonna need the right makeup and he's
like i'm ready just tell me when you're
ready and so we started developing that
i talked to my hairdresser about it a
long time ago so she's always been ready
uh and it was always a matter of getting
the right script i mean even when
i bought the rights in the beginning
walter was not the script writer we
hired several other people to write it
who wrote
interesting scripts but like i said you
know nothing was going to tell this
story in an hour and a half or two hours
it was going to be satisfying for me so
i just couldn't let that happen
there are so many emotional moments and
and heartbreaking moments throughout
this story and at tca you talked about
not being a method actor and how silly
you can sometimes be after an emotional
moment
what was it like to shoot some of those
moments especially with dominique how
long did it take you guys to adjust to
each other's approach to the material
and how you both like to work well i'm
the boss so she had to adjust pretty
quickly
so
if she wanted to go off somewhere and
crash she could run off and cry but i
wasn't going to let her do it right
there on set you know i just grabbed her
and started laughing or just grab her
and tell her oh that was
great that was so amazing like
i felt it uh well you know so you get
feedback immediately i do um because
i've done all that stuff before i get to
work um
i know the emotional place that i need
to go to to get something done uh
sometimes it takes other people the
moment to get there and maybe i am
imposing my will on them by making them
laugh at the end of a scene like that or
or or or
or
or not
investing in
their emotional
sort of output um but that's just who i
am and i want them to to to have a good
time there uh and sometimes when you're
working with people who invest like that
it doesn't feel like they're having a
good time
to me
uh
it's a job of of playing make-believe uh
and you do it effectively and you do it
uh in a way that's not harmful to you
because it's a safe space you're
supposed to be able to safely come into
this space work and give emotionally and
not be
you know harmed by it
there's something so beautiful
there's something so beautiful and
special about the relationship between
ptolemy and robin and
i'm sure you know you've been in this
business a long time you've worked with
a lot of actors you probably can tell
what you're looking for in someone
pretty quick what was it about dominique
i mean i've loved her work since the
deuce but what what did you see in her
that you you know made you want her for
this
um well i saw her in
um
an hbo series with my wife
uh and then i saw her in deuce and then
um i was sitting there watching that uh
some that jamie foxx movie she did in
new orleans with him doing uh doing the
quarantine and i was like ah that's
robin that's her
she had this youthful exuberance but she
also had like
um a depth that you could see and feel
uh that that was a weight to her in
terms of who her character was that she
was not just a fluffy you know kid doing
some other stuff uh and
like you just said um there are there
are heavy moments there are moments of
heavy lifting
in this particular thing that you know
requires a person to uh be able to carry
that emotional weight and depth uh and
she was able to uh
she
she gave us like a 32 play a 32-page
powerpoint on robin
you know it was like she showed up with
stuff because i was like okay all right
here we go and she journals as her
characters and does stuff so i get the
emotional uh uh uh input that she
you know gives
and i also
you know feel like like i said acting
opportunities and
being able to
uh
do what we do
it's like when i was a kid and we played
make-believe you know it's make-believe
we go out we do things we do things and
we laugh about how well we did them or
how much fun we had doing it and i think
acting is that thing for me you know
it's that joyous space where i get to go
and i get to create and like i said
safely and i can invest and i can give
and at the end of it feel very satisfied
that you know i've recreated something
that hopefully will
give an audience uh the feeling that
they paid their money for after playing
a character like nick fury for as long
as you have and we know that you're
going to be doing it again soon you know
coming up
how much do you tweak your dialogue
since you know that character so well
now is it always on the page or do you
like to play with things with him a bit
um
it depends
um
i've been doing nick fury for so long i
know what he sounds like and then you
know
in my ignore i know how he thinks and
how he feels uh and
i know writers writers sit at home and
write
and if
the writer is a fan of
that kind of thing
the superhero genre
they know how to do it um
[Music]
i've had directors who
wrote comic books and did things so when
they say you know say it the way i wrote
it you can kind of go okay so we're
doing comic book speak or
then you'll have directors who'll say
well say it like nick curie would say it
or say it like you as nick fury would
say it then but
which means say it like jules or ordeal
or any of those you know smart ass
characters that you played before help
me and i can accept that too um but
there are times when um
i'm in the midst of doing
or studying
the lines for the next day or the the
the scene that we're doing that i can
tell okay the writer knows what he wants
to say but he hasn't said it yet
so let me help and i'll write it and
then the next day when i go in i'll pull
that person to the side and say look i
know you wrote this but this is
a better way to say that
as nick fury and then go oh my god well
yeah you're nick fury so yeah
is it still a fun experience for you
getting to
you know play a character that long and
return to a character that long yeah
yeah i love nick fury and of course come
on i mean he's a guy who has no
superpowers who's
in charge of people who have superpowers
and they let him be you know so there's
something special about him he's the
leader of men that's very different in
another kind of way
and
it's it's it's very satisfying to be a
part of a world that i admired
for so long when i was a kid i mean
i still buy comic books i still go to a
comic book store i still read them uh
but to be able to be
that character in that you know it's the
same as when i was doing afro samurai or
any of those comic book characters that
it it it means something to be part of a
cultural canaan that that that people
revere and that um they respect in
another way
after 10 years of thinking about this
project and this character
how do you just stop thinking about it i
mean were you able to just close the
book on ptolemy once you rap shooting or
do you think this is a character that
could stick with you forever
um they all stick with you forever in a
specific kind of way
there's always a way to tap back into
them or to think about them and care
about them and to love them um
but yeah you have to move on to the next
story um storytellers tell stories and
unless it's you know part of the same
thing you know if it's not nick fury if
it's not mace windu and star wars you
know carrying on that particular story
then you move on to the next thing or
the next story uh and if that character
is not part of it then you have to
create a whole new character or a whole
new way of thinking about
the thing you're approaching
you've worked with walton goggins before
doing this together what do you like
about working with him as an actor and
how much fun was it to keep calling him
satan
[Laughter]
was bad guy yeah i love
and um you know i mean all those years
that i watched uh
him on the shield
uh and then to go from the shield to
justified i was like oh my god who is
this dude and then after doing
uh
uh django and and hateful to to see him
on the fabulous gemstones go you know
come on i mean walter's that guy
walt comes to work and he comes to work
work and do it you know uh and he's
he's very specific
he's
amazing and committed to what he's doing
uh
and
he's
he's everything that you would expect a
vagabond actor to be
you know he's that guy you know walks
like he goes on walkabouts
he's kind of like wow okay all right
where's walt
and he's just free thinking and in the
world and
his his his his creative energy
is
stupendous
and
and it's infectious and wonderful and
he's just a beautiful human being so
anytime you get a chance to be around
somebody like he is what that show was
the unicorn he is a unicorn and i would
imagine it's fun just to get to call him
satan so oh
come on thank you
because only because he embraces it yeah
thank you he got a cigarette he got
cigarette hanging out of his mouth
yeah
yeah
well thank you so thank you very much
thank you
you